[Musica]
a un certo punto della mia vita mi sono
reso conto che era come se fossi votato
alla ricerca della libertà nel 1988 o
ero dietro la finestra del teatro del
mio teatro e ho alzato per la prima
volta gli occhi verso il carcere di
volterra e ho pensato che lì ci fossero
persone in una maniera estremamente naif
non avevo idea del carcere cosa forse
non ci avevo mai pensato prima come
forse tante di noi o genericamente aveva
un'idea del carcere come forse ce
l'hanno tante e ho pensato che ci
fossero persone tantissime persone che
non avessero niente da fare
dalla mattina alla sera e lì io ho
pensato che potevo creare veramente
potevo creare il mio teatro potevo
creare e far risorgere anche eventi
sembra dalla cenere un'idea
completamente diversa di teatro che li
potevo trovare delle persone che non
avessero in mente già tutto chiaro che
non poi mi parlassero di poesia di
bellezza di arte di cultura e che fosse
possibile riformulare completamente da
zero
un'idea del teatro ho chiesto ho chiesto
non ero sicuro che mi dicesse di sì ho
chiesto siamo in toscana e poi ho
scoperto lentamente dopo ho scoperto una
cosa importante che la toscana era molto
attenta a questi temi
la toscana è stato pieno stato abolire
la pena di morte e dopo un mese nemmeno
mi hanno dato il permesso di entrare
all'interno del calcio e volterra e lì
mi sono reso conto di quanto ero stato
laico mi sono reso conto che c'era una
specchiera possibile realizzare
un'esperienza straordinaria che era
molto ma molto estremamente molto più
ricca di quanto io avessi immaginato
ho cominciato a lavorare lì tutti i
giorni e siamo ormai siamo dopo 31 anni
che lavora lì e mi sono reso e io ero
pagato per farsi inter farvi capire per
fare un laboratorio di 200 ore non sono
rimasto 1500 non sono più uscito ancora
oggi esclusi momenti come questo che
sono
io lavoro lì tutti i giorni cielo entro
le nove e mezza
esco all'una rientro alle 3 esko alle
sette di sera e il mese e mezzo prima
dello spettacolo di queste immagini che
vedete che scorrono dietro a noi
rimaniamo non solo io ma io e tutta una
miriade di collaboratori che lentamente
si sono aggiunte a questa esperienza
incredibile
passiamo liberamente tutta la giornata
mangiavamo all'interno inizia una
mattina usciamo la sera tardissima ho
pensato ed in qualche modo di
trasformare questo luogo di reinventarlo
anche perché quando si parla di teatro
quando si parla di carcere con si parla
di teatro in carcere ma soprattutto se
vale carcere bisogna tener conto e io
sarei curioso di sapere quale
normalmente la vostra idea di carcere io
sono sicuro che è un'idea che è molto
purtroppo influenzata solo e unicamente
da questioni di di cronaca e di cronaca
nera di televisione di immagini
semplicemente veramente terribili che
appartengono all'attualità per me il
carcere era meta e in metafora di
un'altra prigione una prigione molto più
grande nella prigione molto più grande
che comprende tutti quanti noi a volte
sembra quasi una provocazione ma se non
pensassi così sarebbe assolutamente
assurdo normalmente come di la mia
esperienza è stata accompagnata e anche
limitata a volte da questo tipo di
sguardo da uno sguardo che tende a
rendere questa esperienza come
un'esperienza educativa quasi una sorta
di passatempo rieducativa perché questo
è la cosa che più si riesce a capire
questa si comprenda si comprende molto
bene cioè se si pensa che un regista o
comunque un operatore culturale in
maniera molto generica entra all'interno
di un carcere non può entrare perché ha
un obiettivo che è di tipo artistico
culturale ma si può al limite accettare
l'idea che uno entra all'interno di un
carcere perché così forse quelle persone
si rendono conto quindi si pensa che il
teatro possa essere utilizzato come uno
strumento uno strumento per un altro
fine questa è una limitazione enorme una
limitazione norme del teatro
all'imitazione enorme ma anche una
situazione verso gli artisti una persona
che fa parte fa teatro
ma è anche una limitazione enorme
rispetto all'uomo rispetto alle
potenzialità dell'uomo vi assicuro che
non significa e che so che questa volte
può essere sembrare difficile non
significa assolutamente nulla
veramente non significa nulla il fatto
che delle persone stanno in carcere che
le persone che stanno in carcere non
corrispondono questa è stata una delle
mie grandi scoperte e non corrispondono
assolutamente alle azioni compiute anche
questa è un'affermazione che forse può
risultare un pochino a volte c'è
qualcuno del toccherà anche offensiva
era veramente anche offensiva che in
qualche modo non teneva conto di chi
erano veramente queste persone note di
quello che hanno fatto a me tutto questo
aspetto devo dire per fortuna è una cosa
che io sono riuscito a mettere
completamente da parte perché ho pensato
la cosa molto semplice la prigione e
quindi l'idea che dicevo prima la
pensare che la religione è metafora di
un carcere più ampia dove tutti quanti
siamo rinchiusi dentro significa
spostare veramente l'attenzione su un
argomento molto più importante la
prigione sono io sono io coi miei
l'ingrato yo yo armando punzo io coi
miei limiti io con le mie paure
io con tutti i miei condizionamenti
sociali politici culturali religiosi e
quella la prigione che mi preoccupa
molto
mi preoccupa molto e quindi sì forse la
prigione siamo noi
bisogna pensare così bisogna pensare che
quel carcere reale quella vita
quotidiana quella storia che poi in
fondo non interessa quasi a nessuno
pensate che comunque sono dei luoghi che
vengono rimossi dai centri delle città
qui a napoli no e al centro però molto
probabilmente uno passa anche sotto
poggioreale e nemmeno alza lo sguardo
quello che è capitato a me di alzare lo
sguardo e vedere quel luogo in maniera
completamente diversa mi sono reso conto
perché io ho l'ho guardato sotto la luce
non della cronaca non dell'attualità ma
di una possibilità e la possibilità di
trasformazione
io credo che veramente è possibile
muovere e smuovere e trasformare
trasformare tutto e così ho operato ho
pensato chiaramente questa metafora
avrebbe avuto enorme difficoltà e così è
stato
io all'inizio quando entrava all'interno
del carcere
la cosa mi c'è la cosa più semplice che
mi diceva non ha stanato tacca ma poiché
non te le vai al mare
no e io rispondevo io vado al mare
perché non ci fai anche tu se tu stai
lavorando sto lavorando anche io
assicuro che è stata una battaglia
quotidiana ma lo è ancora adesso vi
assicuro che lo è ancora adesso una
battaglia quotidiana per far passare
l'idea che bisogna rimettere l'uomo al
centro e questo bisogna veramente
preoccuparsi dell'uomo al centro e
vederne le potenzialità è stato
possibile far questo anche perché penso
perché molti mi hanno fatto la domanda
come fai a a lavorare come fai a stare
del tempo insieme a quella gente insieme
a quelle persone
io ho pensato che il male deve essere
trasparente deve assolutamente essere
trasparente il mare perché se il male
non è trasparente se la persona
veramente l'azione che ha compiuto per
me e per noi veramente non è possibile
far nulla allora quella quella quella
quell idea del male diventano pietre
diventano pietre che ingabbiano che
chiudono mi sono reso conto anche che
lavorando lì quotidianamente che non è
che io abbia fatto tutto questo mi sono
reso conto delle difficoltà mi sono reso
conto delle difficoltà enormi auto
consapevolezza che era molto difficile
spostare riuscire a creare uno
spettacolo riuscire a far perdere la
percezione del carcere agli stessi
detenuti alle stesse persone con cui ho
un lavoro tutti i giorni partendo questa
percezione del carcere basta vedere un
po questa immagine stanno dietro anche
al pubblico che entra dentro
immancabilmente verrà vi assicuro
immancabilmente quando le persone
vengono lì quello che ci restituiscono è
che il carcere svanisce ed è possibile
veramente pensare in termini di teatro
di arte di cultura di argomenti che non
ha nulla a che vedere col calcio questo
è un risultato uno dei risultati
importanti
enorme che siamo riusciti a raggiungere
ma non tanto perché dobbiamo far
dimenticare il carcere però per quelle
che sono le nostre potenzialità provare
in tutti i modi a cercare di mettere al
centro come dicevo anche prima
l'uomo e riuscirci attraverso questo
tipo di attività
ci sono stati momenti estremamente
difficili ma ci sono state anche momenti
straordinari uno degli attori della
compagnia fortezza faccio un esempio tra
i tantissimi anni e l'arena è uno degli
attori che a un certo pose dc anni
ergastolano oggi definitivamente libero
è diventato un attore protagonista non
dei nostri spettacoli soltanto ma anche
di quelli che sono film tipo 1 con
matteo per farvi un esempio con matteo
garrone reality ma un evento anche
quello abbastanza forte e incredibile
dove matteo che è un regista
veramente è stato e si è comportato in
maniera veramente straordinaria ha
tenuto nascosto il fatto che lavorava
col suo primo attore che era un
ergastolano che a verona fino al premio
che hanno avuto a cannes dove
generalmente i giornalisti chiedevano
dove fosse
l'attore protagonista è lui ha svelato
che era un ergastolano solo in quel
momento senza farsi promozione per
questo tipo di eventi queste sono anche
le persone che hanno accompagnato questo
questo tipo di esperienza
abbiamo fatto di tutto e io ho lavorato
tantissimo su quella che l'idea di
cambiare il tempo la vita all'interno
del carcere è un microcosmo che
corrisponde veramente a quella che è la
nostra vita
non pensate alla al vissuto pensate
all'interno ci sono una serie di
abitudini di di modalità il teatro è
stato per me lo è una pratica una
pratica quotidiana di allontanamento
dalla realtà per la prostituzione di
altre realtà il mio la mia idea è quella
di provare in tutti i modi a creare
altre realtà
quindi la questione di allontanarsi dal
dal carcere della vita quotidiana
provare a pensare il teatro come una
pratica una pratica concreta che ci
permette e vi posso fare un esempio
anche qui quando noi lavoriamo nella
nostra cella che pone una cella teatro
di tre metri per 10 solo negli ultimi
momenti
accade questo quando lavoriamo negli
spazi all'aperto del del carcere
noi lavoriamo in questa stanza e tre
metri e 10 lì è possibile ma questo
appartiene al al teatro è possibile
chiaramente vivere una fine
sta completamente diversa è possibile
sentire parole formulare pensieri avere
un vissuto realmente completamente
diverso
cosa accade quando noi usciamo quando si
esce da quella cella di tre metri per 10
noi abbiamo una sorta di immagine
precise come se fosse una grande mano
che in qualche modo ti afferra per la
gola e tiri trascina assolutamente nella
vita di tutti i giorni
credo che il teatro sia questo e molte
volte questo è stato anche il motivo per
cui sandra dall'interno del carcere ho
bisogno di quelle muraro ho bisogno di
questo contrasto avevo bisogno veramente
di un contrasto fortissimo con la realtà
come fare a vincerla con la realtà che
le realtà non si riproponesse no con
tutta la sua protervia a dire che
fondamentalmente tutto questo è frutto
solo di una utopia
inutile un topia come l'utopia po più
grande se ci pensate bene potrebbe
essere quella di aver pensato che
persone come quelle come alcuni tante
volte mi hanno detto non potevano
assolutamente realizzare nulla oggi la
compagnia fortezza è un'esperienza nota
a livello internazionale è riconosciuta
come un esperienza di teatro come
qualsiasi altra compagnia finanziata
come qualsiasi altra compagnia è questo
veramente non è una questione per
incensare il mio lavoro o quello che
abbiamo fatto ma perché in qualche modo
dimostrato che non c'è nulla che non può
essere trasformato la nostra filosofia
quello qui ho veramente ho cercato di
mettere a fuoco è che tutto deve essere
poter essere messo in discussione tutto
deve poter essere messo in discussione
sei stato possibilmente in discussione
il carcere di volterra significa che
veramente e poi calce potere l'idea di
carcere è veramente possibile fare tutto
siamo riusciti in qualche modo da
spostare i confini enormemente non c'è
nulla che non può essere messo in disco
questo credo che sia un aspetto
estremamente importante poi io non ho
non è talmente è come se non avessi
fatto niente non avessi fatto niente e
veramente c'è un'idea più grande di me
c'è un'idea più grandi mi è così mi sono
spiegato il tutto ci avete più grandi
meno un'idea che viene dapprima di me
forse un'idea che apparteneva a tanti
altri
persone a tante persone come si è visto
anche qui ci sono persone che agiscono
in diversi anni di un'idea che guarda
all'uomo e con la speranza con una
prospettiva enorme guardando in avanti e
questa idea mi attraversa forse io mi
sono messo a disposizione di questa idea
e spero di riuscire a farlo ancora per
tantissimo ancora per questa idea che
vada oltre che arrivi anche verso chi
normalmente non ha invece nessun
orizzonte speranza e pensa che la vita è
chiusa dentro delle gabbie precise
intoccabili indiscutibili
[Applauso]
[Musica]